PAUL LEE: My name is Paul Lee.
And I'm a product
manager here at Google.
For the past several
years, my wife and I
have had the pleasure
of volunteering
with the International
Justice Mission.
And today, I am
privileged to introduce
its founder and CEO Gary Haugen.
So who is Gary Haugen?
I didn't fact check this.
So we'll go with this.
This is what the
internet says Gary is.
Gary is the youngest
of six kids and hails
from nearby Sacramento.
During elementary
school, he decided
he want to be a lawyer, inspired
by the examples of Lincoln
and MLK.
He played football
in high school,
with the scene crew
cut he generously
shares with us today.
And in 1981, he departed
for the lesser school
in the East Coast, Harvard.
After graduating in 1985,
Gary traveled to South Africa
during the apartheid
era, and worked
with Michael Cassidy
and Desmond Tutu
at the National Initiative
for Reconciliation.
For those of you who
were born in the '80s,
this was during
the apartheid era.
And as an example of what
it was like in that period,
in one instance Gary was
detained by security forces
for attending a
multiracial church
service without permission.
This was a world at that time.
In 1988, Gary started law school
at the University of Chicago.
And during that time, he worked
for the Lawyers Committee
on Human Rights.
He investigated crimes like
Lupeau Massacre of 1987,
which involved the
execution of 17 civilians
by soldiers in
the Filipino army.
After law school, Gary joined
the Department of Justice
as a trial attorney in
the Civil Rights Division.
Gary met his wife,
Jan, during this time.
They now have four kids.
And in 1994, Gary was
detailed to the UN Center
for Human Rights, where he
directed the UN's investigation
of the genocide in Rwanda.
I actually have on my
computer, but didn't
send it to Ruthie in time,
a photo, my favorite photo
that I've seen in
the IJM office.
It's a picture of a
giant military camouflage
helicopter in the
background, Gary
dressed pretty much
like he is right now,
and scores of kids
running towards him.
And I asked the
staff there, what
is that photo,
because it's just kick
butt to see this giant
military transport and all
these kids and Gary.
It turns out that it was
from 2006, his first trip
back to Rwanda where he
visited a remote area that
was part of his investigation.
That time was pivotal,
and if we go back to 1994,
Gary, when he worked
for the investigation,
collected with his team,
testimony of physical evidence
from 100 mass
graves and massacre
sites across the country.
Allow me to share because I
can't do this justice, the "New
Yorker" subscription as
experienced from an article
they wrote about this in 2009.
"Gary was sickened to come
across charred piles of bodies
in a church where Tutsi had
expected to find sanctuary.
He took down the
testimony of a father
who saw his three small children
hacked to death with machetes.
At one massacre site,
Haugen rolled back
the decaying body of
a woman, and found
the corpse of her
child beneath her."
End quote.
Over the next 17 years--
sorry, let me back up.
Moved by this experience,
Gary returned to the US
and went into start-up
planning mode.
He would build a
new organization
that would not simply
plead for victims,
but would actually rescue them.
This organization would
focus on four key areas.
Victim relief, perpetrator
accountability, aftercare
and structural reform.
In 1997, one year prior
to Google's own start,
Gary found IJM with
one employee, desks
for two interns
in an office park.
Over the next 17 years, IJM
would establish operations
in 10 countries
and earn the right
to investigate and
prosecute crimes,
working with local
law enforcement
and public prosecutors.
You won't see these
videos, but I've seen them.
And what you'll see if you were
actually at IJM headquarters
is pictures of staff
putting their lives
on the line in the back of
SWAT vans, raiding brothels,
chasing out the aggressors
and rescuing the victims.
It's a pretty
powerful experience.
The organization now
includes 600 staff,
including an
investigations team led
by Mark Clookie, the former
director of NCIS-- yes, he
did do two cameos on a TV show--
a policy team led by Holly
Burkhalter, former advocacy
director for Human Rights
Watch, as well as 200 lawyers.
Today IJM is a $50 million
human rights agency
that, in the words of the
"Atlantic"'s Stephen Bradley,
investigates and prosecutes the
worst crimes, the worst evils,
around the globe.
Human trafficking, sexual
exploitation, slavery,
police brutality, violence
in all manifestation
but principally violence
against the world's poor.
Over the last years,
I've served on the board.
I've worked in my career
with over 40 non-profits.
And some of these
non-profits are amazing.
I think they do incredible work.
This is the first time I
worked with a nonprofit that
has as its dashboard monitoring
loss of life and limb
to staff, tracking assassination
attempts on their staff workers
in the field.
The work they do is
really incredible.
In 2013 alone, IJM
rescued over 2,000 victims
and secured over
100 convictions.
That's in one year.
Over the past 18 years, IJM has
rescued over 18,000 victims,
trained 13,000
officers and officials
and secured over 700
convictions, much of them
in the past five years alone.
However, more
significant than these
numbers is growing evidence
that IJM's model is beginning
to result in structural
transformation and hopefully
permanent change.
A Gates Foundation-funded
study, for instance,
found that the number of minors
available for exploitation
in metro Ceba in the Philippines
plummeted 79% over four years.
As a result of the
investigation's work in 2012,
Gary received the Trafficking
In Persons Report Hero Reward.
IJM was also one of
11 organizations that
received a combined $11 million
grant from Google.org in 2011.
A significant
portion of that grant
was allocated to
syndicate IJM's model
to other nonprofits in India.
And in the first nine
months of 2013 alone,
that initiative and your
money, Google's money,
resulted in 830 victim rescues.
Earlier this month,
Oxford University Press
released Gary's latest
book "The Locust Effect:
Why the End of Poverty
Requires the End of Violence,"
written with Victor Boutros,
who's here in the front
as well, federal prosecutor.
Let me just say, amongst
the many endorsements
that came from Bill Clinton,
Anne Marie Slaughter,
Madeleine Albright,
I think my favorite
is from Madeleine Albright
that says "the book is
a much-needed argument
for reducing violence
against the poor,
and a demonstration
through firsthand
stories that are
both shocking and true of
why that goal is so vital.
The book is both a vehicle for
sharing voices rarely heard
and a declaration of faith
that with sufficient will,
there are ways to halt
the physical and financial
exploitation of
the disadvantaged.
By reminding us that basic
legal protections are not
a privilege but a
universal right,
Gary Haugen has
issued a moral call
to arms that informs the
brain and touches the heart."
That's my hope for us today,
that we'll keep our brains
and our hearts open as we
welcome Gary to Google.
Please join me.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY HAUGEN: Thanks,
Paul, very much
for the extravagant
introduction.
I appreciate that you got
all the material from my mom,
and you did a great,
great job with it.
Thanks very much.
And Kevin, thanks for dragging
all your friends here.
He told me this is the
smartest people at Google.
So congratulations for that.
Or the people who couldn't
afford to buy a book,
so the first 10 who
showed up got a book.
So way to go.
I'm glad you mentioned the hair.
I did a Google
Hangout in New York,
with your colleagues
in New York.
And Justin introduced me.
That pretty much was
the entire introduction
was just making fun of my hair.
So this was really
cool in the '50s.
It really, really was.
Anyways, it's marvelous
to get to be with you.
Thank you for the
Google grant, that
allowed us to replicate
the work in India.
Thousands of people
now have been
rescued as a result of that.
I've been in places
of literal slavery
and are now free because
of the willingness
to engage in this work and to
train others in how to do it.
But I'd like to start this
afternoon with a story much,
much closer to home-- actually
just a few hours from here
across the California border in
Oregon, in a rural county where
there was a woman,
not too long ago,
who was home alone at night.
It's dark out.
And she starts to
hear an intruder begin
to break open her side door.
And she looks over,
and sees this man
breaking his way into her house.
It's terrifying,
especially for her,
because two weeks before,
this same man in her community
had put her in the hospital
through an assault.
And now he is clawing
his way into her house.
So she does what any
sort of terrified person
would do in their
house in America.
She picks up the phone,
and she calls 911.
And what proceeds is a pretty
horrific 10 minute conversation
with this 911 operator
who proceeds to explain
that due to budget cuts
in her rural county,
law enforcement is only
operating on the weekdays.
And this is a weekend.
And so she's simply
explaining to her
that you don't have law
enforcement in your area.
Listen to this
for just a moment.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-I don't have anybody
to send out there.
Uh, you know, obviously if
he comes inside the residence
and assaults you, can
you ask him to go away?
Or do you know if he's
intoxicated or anything?
-I've already asked him.
I've already told him
I was calling you.
He's broken in before, busted
down my door, assaulted me.
-Uh huh.
Is there any way you can
safely leave the residence?
-No, I can't.
Because he's blocking
pretty much my only way out.
-Well, the only thing I can
do is give you some advice.
And call the sheriff's
office tomorrow,
Obviously, if he comes in and
unfortunately, has a weapon
or is trying to cause
you physical harm,
that's a different story.
The sheriff's office
doesn't work up there.
I don't have anybody to send.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
GARY HAUGEN: The Sheriff's
office doesn't work up there.
I don't have anybody to send.
Of course, what happens is
that man tears into that place,
assaults her, chokes
her, brutally rapes her.
This is what happens
if there's no law
enforcement in your area, if
there's no one to send for you.
And yet, this book
that we've written,
"The Locust Effect,"
what this is about
is the story that there are
about four billion people
in our world who have no
access to law enforcement.
Especially for those
who are poorest,
a study was done by the UN that
says quote-- listen to this--
"most poor people live outside
the protection of law."
Now that's a phrase
that we can sort of
read and just let wash over us.
But I think there's perhaps
nothing quite like this phone
call that allows us
for just a moment
to step into the shoes
of the common poor person
in the developing world
who has no access to law
enforcement and the terror that
that represents in their lives.
So that's the big number.
Four billion people
do not have access
to law enforcement
that will actually
protect them from violence.
But what does that actually look
like in the developing world?
Well, it looks like
this in Bolivia,
where if you were
to sexually assault
a child in Bolivia,
statistically,
you would actually be at greater
risk of slipping in the shower
and dying than you
would have ever
being sent to jail
for that crime.
Imagine a state of
such impunity-- yes,
it's completely against the law.
But the problem for the poor is
not that they don't get laws,
it's they don't get
law enforcement.
This means, in India and
other places in South Asia,
if you enslave someone,
literally enslave someone,
you're at greater risk of being
struck by lightning than you
are of ever being sent to
jail for the crime of slavery.
This is a profound
and massive phenomenon
across the developing world
that receives very, very
little mention at all,
which is the utter breakdown
of basic criminal justice
systems in the developing
world.
And what it has done, then,
is unleash this epidemic
of violence against the poor.
And in "The Locust
Effect," this is really
what we're trying to
bring to the surface.
Because if I say the
word global poverty
and if you try to bring
sort of images to mind,
what comes to mind?
I mean immediately
you start to think,
don't you, about dirty shacks.
You think about the dirty water.
You think of sickness.
You think of kids who
can't go to school.
You think of lack of capital,
the need for microfinance,
all those sorts of needs.
One of the things that does not
commonly come to the surface
for us is the way
that to be poor
is to be chronically
vulnerable to violence.
But the problem is
all that violence
stays below the surface.
Many of us have traveled
to the developing world.
And we've seen the dirty shacks,
the dirty water, the hunger,
the people who are sick.
But very few of us will ever
just visually see the violence.
And so it takes something
for us to be traveling
into that subterranean
world to see
what that violence looks like.
And this is what we try
to do in the opening
chapters of "The Locust
Effect" is take you
with a common poor person
in the developing world
to see what this
violence is like.
And we begin with
the first category
of most pervasive violence
among the poor in the developing
world.
And that's basically
gender violence.
That's sexual violence
and domestic abuse
of women and girls.
It is, in the collapse
of law enforcement,
open season on women and girls.
In fact, gender
violence accounts
for more death and disability
for women and girls
between the age of 15 and
44 than malaria, cancer, car
accidents and war combined.
This is why we're calling this
epidemic "every day violence,"
because, again, if we are
familiar with the violence
against the poor,
most of the time
we're thinking about the sort of
catastrophic spasms of violence
that are in the headlines.
Like the wars, the
conflicts, and for sure,
those do decimate
people's lives.
And I know something about
that myself, of course,
having been the director of
the genocide investigation
in Rwanda where,
as Paul mentioned,
I just was given this list by
UN military intelligence of 100
different mass graves
and massacre sites.
And we just tediously sorted
through these thousands
and thousands of
people who'd been
butchered by their neighbors.
And when you're doing
that work, especially
as an investigator, what
you're really trying to do
is recreate visually
how did this happen
from the forensic
evidence that's there.
And what is it like for
that family pressed up
against the wall of that
stadium or that school
or that cathedral, as they
see those machetes coming
towards them?
And the thing that
was so manifest to me
is that, yes, all these
Rwandans were overwhelmingly
very, very poor.
The average Rwandan is
living off about $0.65 a day.
But in that moment of
terror, when the machetes
are coming towards
you and your family,
you're actually not
crying out for some food.
You're not crying
out for a doctor.
out for a microloan.
You're not crying out for
a teacher in education.
You're crying out for
someone to restrain
the hand of that machete.
And this is the thing that
makes violence different.
It is a profound
affliction of the poor,
but it's different than the
other problems that we engage.
And this first category
of massive abuse
is gender violence.
But like so many things,
it stays below the surface.
At the beginning
of the book, I just
invite readers to come with
me to meet Lucilla who's
this woman that I met in a small
town in the Andean mountains
in Peru.
Very common woman, lives in
a town that you would not
necessarily notice or
pay any attention to,
except for the fact it has
a rate of sexual assault
that is worse than the sexual
assault rates that were coming
out of the worst war
zones of the Congo.
And if you follow through
the story of Lucilla
as she has to endure
the rape and murder
of her eight-year-old
daughter, who's just dumped out
on the street one night.
And to follow Lucilla in
what it is like for her
to try to get justice in a
totally broken criminal justice
system.
Gender violence is
this massive epidemic
against women and girls who
are poorest and most vulnerable
in the world.
The second massive category
of violence against the poor
is a kind of violence
that actually
keeps people in poverty by
force, and that's slavery.
You may already know that there
are about 30 million people
held in slavery in
the world today.
These are not people held
in slave-like conditions
or metaphorical slavery--
in actual slavery.
At IJM, we've met
thousands of them.
And thanks to
Google's work with us
have also been able to
bring rescue to thousands.
But there remain
actually more people
in slavery today than in any
other time in human history.
Mind boggling, right?
It's true that a smaller
proportion of human beings
are in slavery.
That's true.
A smaller proportion
of the economy
is produced by slave labor.
That's true.
But there's just so
many more human beings
that the absolute number
of people in slavery
is greater now than any
other time in history.
One of the ways we try to
bring readers into this again
subterranean reality
is to take people
to Bangalore, which is sort of
the shining high-tech capital
in India, really sort of the
icon of the booming economies
of India.
But an Indian lawyer takes me
on a drive just a few minutes
outside the beltway
of Bangalore and shows
me a brick factory
where scores of people
are held literally as slaves
working seven days a week,
12 to 14 hours a day,
making and carrying bricks.
And anybody's who's
ever tried to run away
from the facility
is chased down,
dragged back and beaten
in front of the others.
In fact, when this one
couple was able to escape,
the owner of the brick factory
was able to go to their village
and actually kidnap and
hold some family members
and neighbors as
hostages, and just
publicly proclaim until you
bring me back my slaves,
I'm going to continue to detain
and torture their neighbors.
In other words, he was
very happy to let everyone
know that he was exercising
this kind of violence,
because he had zero
fear that he would ever
be brought to account
under the law.
So I got a chance to sit
with Mariamam for instance,
as she explained what
it was like to live
as a slave with her
family and about two dozen
other over of her
neighbors as literal slaves
in the 21st century.
So the book takes us again
to that subterranean world
that we would otherwise
have no idea about.
The third sort of
catastrophic form
of violence against the
poor, surprisingly perhaps,
is police abuse.
It turns out that
the World Bank did
this study called
"Voices of the Poor"
which gave to the tens of
thousands of poor people
just the chance to say what is
it about your poverty that's
most painful to you.
And the study was
very rigorous, and one
of things it was
saying that police
and courts in the
developing world
actually make poor people
poorer and less secure.
What?
I mean that's like
a finding that
says the hospitals in
the developing world
are making everybody sicker.
Or the schools are
actually the places
where everyone's
prohibited from reading.
This is what public
justice systems
have become in the
developing world--
places actually of harm.
If you're poor, you run away
from the police to be safe.
You don't run to the
police to be safe.
One of the
manifestations of this
is the reality of pretrial
detention, where the police are
able to throw people
into jails and hold them
without any charge or trial.
In any given year, there's
about 10 million people,
overwhelmingly the poorest, who
are held in pretrial detention.
What you don't see in
that statistic though,
that of the tens of
millions of people
who are attached to
those families, when
the breadwinner is
taken into prison,
the way that devastates
the capacity of that family
to move forward.
So police abuse is the
third and just horrific form
of violence
confronting the poor.
The fourth, interestingly,
is violent land theft.
Just a way that the poor
will have their land stolen
from them by people
of power and violence.
In any given year,
about 5 million people
will get themselves violently
ejected off of their land.
And if you were
to look at, well,
who's most vulnerable
to this, it
turns out that widows are,
especially widows in Africa.
As the AIDS epidemic
has devastated
much of the male population, it
leaves these families, right?
And what happens is that
stronger families will come
and they'll just throw a
widow like Susan and her kids
off their land.
One of the things that's amazing
that I had no understanding of
was the idea that widows like
Susan in the developing world
support a half a
billion orphans.
So you imagine a poor
person who their sort
of one asset for
moving out of poverty
is their little plot of
land, which gives them
a little shelter and then also
the little garden where they're
able to raise some food.
But if you steal that
land away, you've
taken a very most basic means
for progress away from them.
And you've left
them in destitution.
So that's the fourth
largest pervasive form
of violence against the
poor is violent land theft.
The things that we want to
bring forth from the book
is not only this sort of
subterranean world of violence
that we might not be aware of--
and why aren't we aware of it?
It's hard to visualize--
but secondly, there's
human beings actively hiding it.
Dirty water does not
actively hide itself.
Nor do shacks nor generally
do diseases, but human beings
when they commit violence,
they work hard to hide it.
And likewise, the
survivors and victims
of abuse also because of
fear and shame many times
are also hiding it as well.
So the book is trying to bring
this back up to the surface.
But not only that,
but help people
begin to think about what
are the implications of this
for our dreams for
the poor, that is,
that they would be able
to get out of poverty.
And this is why we're calling
it "The Locust Effect,"
because one of the pictures
we want people to have
is just the way that
over the millennia,
these poor farm
communities, who are trying
to scrape their way out of
poverty by all this farm work,
in a single day would
see the locusts descend
and just destroy
all of those years
of hard work in a single day.
And this is the way
predatory violence
works in the life of the poor.
In a moment, they descend
and destroy that work.
But not only did it destroy
the fruit of the farm work,
but what's interesting
about the locust is
that farm work doesn't
stop the locust.
So not only does
violence destroy
the fruit of the
efforts of the poor
and the efforts of those
who attempt to help them,
but also the traditional things
that we do to assist the poor,
they don't stop the violence.
So that suggests
that we need to start
talking about
poverty differently
and start doing things
differently about poverty
as well.
So then that raises
the question that we
try to address a bit in
the book is my goodness,
why are criminal justice
systems so completely useless,
backwards, brutal and broken
in the developing world?
And there is four pretty
interesting surprises
that explain this.
One of them, which if you
traveled in the developing
world you probably noticed,
but it didn't really
come to your mind what it
was that you are seeing.
And that is, you probably went
to a restaurant and a hotel,
and you exchanged
some money, and you
went to some other places,
novels and almost everywhere
that you and I would go
in the developing world,
someone will be there
with a gun guarding you.
Because with the collapse
of public justice systems
in the developing world,
what's come into its place?
Well, people with wealth
and money and businesses
have set up a completely
parallel system
of private security.
So now, in fact, in a
country like Guatemala,
private security forces
are seven times larger
than the public police force.
In Africa, the largest
employer on the continent
is private security.
In a way that almost we have
not remarked upon at all,
a massive social
transformation has taken place
in the developing world, where
security, instead of it being
a public good that's
provided to everybody
through public institutions of
policing and criminal justice
system has been privatized.
So now there's two kinds of
people in the developing world.
Those who can pay for their own
security and those who cannot
afford to pay for security,
cannot pay to be safe,
and so they're not.
So we now have to picture 2 and
1/2 billion people who live off
less than $2 a day, who
cannot purchase into their own
security and are living
in this lawless chaos.
What is the impact for them on
trying to get out of poverty?
There's several
other explanations
in the book that are
pretty surprising about how
it is that criminal justice
systems and law enforcement has
become so broken in
the developing world.
But then what we
try to do is finally
sort of pivot towards
some hope, because I
realize I've pretty much
decimated your Wednesday
right here that was going
along very well just fine.
And then we hear about
all this massive violence
and human suffering.
It's like, thank
you very much, Gary.
I'll take a nap now.
But we've been at this work
now for almost 20 years.
And you think we'd be pretty
much in a fetal position
somewhere, because of all the
sort of overwhelming corruption
and abuse and violence.
But actually I have never
been and we've never
been more hopeful about
coming to a tipping
point of transformation
in the developing world.
And why is that?
Where is the hope come from?
The first place that hope
comes from is history.
Most of us just
have never thought
for a few minutes of like,
where did our own reasonably
functioning public
justice systems come from?
Our public justice system,
our police and courts
aren't perfect, for sure.
I spent a career at the
Department of Justice
going after corrupt and brutal
cops in the United States.
And my co-author Victor
d does this currently
and works in the
Civil Rights Division
of the Department of Justice.
All the sort of abuses that
happen anywhere in the world
can also happen here.
But we breathe, like the
invisible oxygen in the air,
functioning criminal justice
systems that keep us safe.
So we are outraged, are
we not, when it turns out
that law enforcement can't
come to my house right now.
That seems like a completely
intolerable situation.
Because we have reasonably
functioning justice systems.
But if you lived in
the San Francisco Bay
Area 120 years ago, what
kind of law enforcement
would you be experiencing?
What I could tell
you for sure is
that it would be either
non-existent brutal or corrupt
or completely
captured by whatever
local political
party was in charge.
In fact, what we do
in the book is we
set forth these various
examples, these scenarios,
and have you try to guess.
Is this one of the familiar
cities that you enjoy and walk
in currently and a story of
what their public justice
system looked like
140 years ago?
Or is this a current city
in the developing world?
And the descriptions are
indistinguishable, one
from another.
In other words, criminal justice
systems that work and protect
people, they don't
descend from heaven
as wonderfully operating.
They always start out
brutal and corrupt.
And a fight is engaged to make
them actually serve everybody,
so that everybody's
protected from violence.
And this is the history that
most of us have just forgotten.
But what it reminds us is
that this is possible actually
for those who are living in
the developing world as well.
So that's the other way we begin
to turn to look for hope too,
because there actually
are some stories
and examples around
the world now
where some best
practices are beginning
to emerge of how the
international community can
join with local
champions in the fight
for trying to secure
justice for the poorest.
One of the best
examples that we share
in the book is the one
that Paul alluded to,
which was this experiment we
did with the Gates Foundation
in the second largest
city of the Philippines
called Ceba which had a
terrible problem with child sex
trafficking.
And we were given
this grant to look at,
well, let's see if
we can do two things.
Number one can we stand up local
law enforcement, the police
and the courts so they
actually effectively enforce
the law against child
sex trafficking.
Is that even possible?
Because maybe it's so
hopelessly corrupt and brutal
that's not even possible.
And if that does happen,
will that actually
reduce the amount of
violence against kids
in the commercial sex trade?
Or is this just
hopelessly some part
of a massive problem of
poverty that will never
be affected by good
law enforcement.
Well, outside auditors
went in before the project
began and sort of
drew a baseline
of how much
victimization of children
there was in the
commercial sex trade.
And the goal of the project
over a four-year period of time
was to try to demonstrate
a 20% reduction
in the victimization
of these kids.
That would have hit the ball
out of the park, home run.
Gates Foundation would have
been super, super proud
of this amazing winning project.
But after four years of standing
up local law enforcement
by deploying, as
IJM does everywhere
in the world, local,
indigenous Filipino lawyers,
criminal investigators
and social workers
to actually turn law
enforcement around,
what we saw after four short
years was their auditors
found a 79% reduction in
the victimization of kids
in the commercial sex trade.
Why is that?
Fundamentally, you
learn two things.
Number one crimes against the
poor is crime of opportunity.
You do it, because you
can get away with it.
And it turns out that when
you can't get away with it,
you don't do it anymore.
It also turns out that
people who oppress the poor
are not brave people.
And when they start to feel
a sense of reasonable risk
that they could pay
a price for that,
they just leave them alone.
There are a number of
stories in the book that
begin to show, not only
from IJM but from other NGOs
around the world, other
government organizations that
are beginning to turn this
plague of violence around.
Our invitation to you
is just really two-fold.
One is to help us to change
the conversation about poverty.
/ of you have probably been
engaged because you even
came here this afternoon.
You probably have some
heart for the struggle
against poverty in our world.
And we are at an
inflection point
in history of making really
some tremendous improvements.
But we're also
stalling out in terms
of trying to help the
the 2 and 1/2 billion
who are living off $2 a day, in
them actually breaking through.
And so what we
would want to do is
begin to make sure
that we don't fail
to include the
problem of violence
when we talk about poverty.
So I would love it if you
got a hold of the book,
read it, got yourself educated,
so you yourself are capable
advocate of just almost
always asking the question.
Yeah, but what
about the violence?
And how are we dealing
with the violence?
And how are we strengthening
local law enforcement
to be able to address it?
The second thing we
would love for you to do
is not only get the book,
educate yourself, participate
in the discussion,
but right now, there
is a very, very important
conversation going on
with the United Nations about
the Millennium Development
Goals.
You might have heard about this.
In the year 2000,
the UN put together
from the international community
a blueprint-- the blueprint--
for trying to address
poverty and to try
to make massive
progress over 15 years.
So they came up with these
eight Millennium Goals.
Well, in many
respects, those have
been really helpful
and very powerful.
But one of the grand
mistakes that was made
was that they drew up a
blueprint to address poverty
and didn't say a word about
violence, this horrific force
that undercuts so
much of what's being
done to try to assist the poor.
An example of
that, for instance,
is girls' education in the
developing world, which
is this amazingly powerful way
to actually bring prosperity
to a whole community, not
only for the individual girls
but for that whole community.
The problem is now
studies show that one
of the primary
reasons girls don't
go to school in the developing
world is because of violence.
Violence on the way
to school, violence
in school, violence
in the home that
keeps them from going to school.
And so we want to make
sure that as the UN now
is rewriting the Millennium
Development Goals, so
that in the year
2015, they'll launch
this new blueprint for
addressing poverty,
we just simply
want to make sure,
let's not leave out violence.
It's a bit like
the AIDS epidemic
when it began to really
roll through the developing
world in the '90s.
And millions of people
were being decimated.
Really you could not be serious
about addressing poverty
in the developing
world if you are not
willing to confront
the problem of AIDS,
because whatever it
is that you are doing,
AIDS is going to show
up and impact it.
In the same way, we are hoping
to engage the conversation
about poverty in the
developing world to say,
unless you're dealing with
the problem of violence
and the lawlessness
unleashed by the collapse
of criminal justice
system, it's going
to roll over almost everything
else you're trying to do.
And so we would love
it if you would go
to the
locusteffect.com/petition,
and just joined
a petition there.
That goes to the Secretary
General of the UN.
It ought to just be
millions of common people
who say, as they did with regard
to the AIDS epidemic, hey,
I'm not an expert
about everything,
but I care about this stuff.
And it seems to make sense to
me that if we don't address
violence, we're not going
to make the progress that we
want in addressing poverty.
Simple as that.
But what I can tell you is
that this stuff matters.
And it's a tremendous
way for you
not only to engage
yourself, but begin
to mobilize all of your
networks into the fight.
So that's all I have to
share this afternoon.
I'd be happy to take
questions or interaction.
AUDIENCE: In your first example,
the local police station
had lost funding.
So my question to you would
be in these developing world,
where the governments
themselves often
lack funding, if you
have any ideas for
had to attack that angle.
GARY HAUGEN: Yeah.
In many respects, we'll
look in the developing world
and we'll see, especially
in low income countries,
you think, wow, they really
don't have enough resources
in the country to
actually provide
for decent law enforcement.
Except when you look
at all the dollars
that are being spent
on private security.
And then you realize,
oh, in the aggregate,
this economy actually
has plenty of money
to be able to provide for public
security, public law and order.
And so what it takes
is a groundswell
of social demand within
these communities--
a groundswell of demand
to actually reallocate
resources to the priority of
providing for law enforcement.
That's why I want to
emphasize this is not
a problem is going to be solved
from outsiders paratrooping
in and setting up
American justice systems
or something like that.
This is a fight that the
community itself, the nation,
must own.
And part of that is to
rally the community,
to begin to demand that the
public justice system is well
provided for.
So that's one of the things
the International Justice
Mission does.
And a number of
the other examples
that we given in the
book is how do we
come alongside local
champions in those communities
and help resource them to
be able to draw attention
to the problem, but
also realign resources
so they're providing
for a public justice
system that cares for all.
One of the amazing, of
course, examples of this
is the country of Georgia, which
is a former Soviet republic,
which in 2003 was ranked
something like 145 out of 190
countries as most corrupt.
It was ranked as more corrupt
than any country that we
work in, especially the police.
But there was a demand
amongst the citizenry
and a new election that
brought to bear leaders
into power who began
to attack corruption.
And they started with
police corruption.
And the thing that
they found was
that police officers in Georgia
would pay a $10,000 bribe
in order to get a job,
for which they were
paid by the government
$10 a month.
Why would you do that?
Because basically you've
been given a license
to then extort
money from people.
And then those high authorities
in the Georgian government
also figured that out.
Let me see, I get $10,000 bribe.
We need a lot of police.
Because the more police we have,
the more bribe money I get.
And so they have this
bloated police force
that was ill trained and
ill equipped and completely
abusive.
So when this new leadership came
in, the first thing they did
is they fired 16,000 police
officers in a single day, sent
them home and the
city was safer.
Then they rebuilt the
police from the ground up.
And they were able to
pay them good wages,
provide them with
good equipment,
and provide them with
good management that
was able to secure integrity
to the police force.
And the transformation for the
common person is tremendous.
So the resources are there.
It's just how you allocate them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's a sort of
a stereotype about violence
against the poor,
which is maybe part
of the self-defense mechanism,
like you're saying, well,
after this, we'll feel
like going and taking a nap
and forgetting about the
whole thing, which is, oh,
those poor people over
in the poor part of town.
They have all this violence
in their community.
They're all beating
each other up.
But as long as they don't
come into my neighborhood
and break into my house, I just
don't have to think about it.
I'm wondering
especially, it seems
like this might differ across
the different categories
of violence you
were talking about,
but to what extent are
we looking at lawlessness
within the poor community, and
to what extent are we really
looking at the people who
are much better off going
in systematically taking the
land, as you were saying,
from the poor and
enslaving the poor and so
forth, as opposed to domestic
violence, which might be more
of a poor-on-poor
or kind of thing.
GARY HAUGEN: Yeah.
It's both.
Poor-on-poor violence is sort of
relatively-poor-against-the-poorest
violence.
Right?
So the opening
story, for instance,
of the rape and murder of the
child in Bolivia in this town,
that was committed
by the wealthy family
inside the town, who are not
wealthy from our perspective.
But in that town, they are
the wealthy or powerful ones.
So it is sort of the strong
preying upon the weak.
But it is also true that,
for instance, the people who
run slave operations in rice
factories, brick factories,
these are people of
substantial economic power
and substantial political power.
So those kinds of
crimes and especially
the land theft,
those are also crimes
that have substantial
economic power behind them,
so you are dealing with people
who are actually making money
off the violence.
There's not a lot of people
making money off malaria.
There's not a lot of
people making money off
of contaminating water or
making hospitals run badly.
You could make up an
instance, I guess,
in which that's the case.
But for the most part,
that's not the case.
But there is a massive
business of economic advantage
from violence against
other human beings.
And if you don't have
a good system that's
prepared to fight
that, that's going
to roll all over
the most vulnerable.
AUDIENCE: Two kind
of related questions.
Or it might just be that
I'm trying to jam two in.
One, you made a good case for
how violence affects the poor.
I'm curious about flipping
that around and thinking
about how does poverty
actually create violence.
How much of this is from
people being poor and having
no other opportunities?
How much does that impact
the police situation
where you talk about police
who are very underpaid?
And getting this
into the equation,
the second part
of the question is
where is the most
leverage to this.
There were some big
numbers thrown out
around 4 billion people without
law enforcement protection,
30 million in
slavery, where do we
get the most
leverage to actually
have the most impact
on a problem like this?
GARY HAUGEN: From
our perspective,
there's no question that
the biggest leverage comes
from a credible criminal
deterrent in the community.
Because crime proceeds
along elasticity to risk.
And different kinds of
crime is sensitive to risk
in different ways.
So if you have social
pathology, sort of deviancy,
that the pedophilia's sort
of a crime, where somebody,
just out of deviancy, is
going to commit that crime.
And actually, it's not
very responsive to risk.
You can ratchet up the
law enforcement on that,
and those people commit
those crimes anyways.
And they end up going to jail.
So it's not very
responsive to risk.
Also true with
crime of necessity,
where some one feels like,
I gotta commit this crime.
And., that's what a
lot of state crime
is that's committed
by governments.
They think I have to
torture this guy in order
to stay in power.
So this is a crime
of necessarity.
So that responsiveness to
risk is also not that great.
I also crime of
desperation where
you feel like I got
a steal the bread,
I have to hijack the car
because my family's starving,
and so this is necessity.
That's also not very
responsive to risk.
But the vast,
vast, vast majority
of crime against the poor
is crime of opportunity.
You do it because you
can get away with it.
And what you find
there on the curve
is that as soon as there
is a little increase
in the risk, that falls
very, very sharply,
especially things like any
kind of crime of opportunity
that produces an
economic reward.
That's certainly like slavery.
That step drops off like 79%
in a four-year period of time
when people who
were doing it just
for the purposes of making money
find that the risk calculation
has changed so we have seen
the greatest returns from just
making sure that those
who would be drawn
to that crime against the
poor feel like they have
a reasonable chance
of going to jail.
That means you get rid
of all the soft crime.
That will leave you
with a hard crime, which
is the crime of desperation,
the crime of necessity,
the crime of social deviancy.
And in the West,
that's what we're
trying to mostly battle
in our communities.
But we have a really
different struggle
in the developing
world, where there's
a tremendous amount of soft
crime, crime of opportunity
that hasn't been
addressed at all.
And we will have to eventually
get to the other stuff.
But right now, the
massive numbers
are coming from just
pure opportunity.
Yeah.
The second question was
about-- the prior question--
AUDIENCE: The first was, I
think, what you mentioned,
which is the crimes of
necessity or desperation,
that how much does
poverty itself create
the violence versus violence
exacerbating the poverty?
GARY HAUGEN: A cycle.
They're interrelated.
But it's a mistake
to imagine that you
have to wait to solve poverty
before you can drastically
reduce the amount of
violence against the poor.
You can addressed
violence because it's
driven by the incentives of
the perpetrator, substantially.
And so those risk calculations
are very, very powerful.
You will need to address
the other sort of caught
complicated social
causes for crime.
But a massive
amount of it can be
addressed by addressing the
incentives of the perpetrators
unlike dirty water
or disease they
don't have human will behind it.
All crime does.
And so you affect the
incentives of the perpetrators
quite powerful and faster than
you might otherwise think.
AUDIENCE: I realize you're
focusing on the developing
world.
And you just
mentioned that, say,
in a society like ours
in the United States,
we deal with maybe, you say
less of this soft crime.
More the hard crime.
I feel like we have the same
thing happening in the United
States where money
pays for protection.
For instance, our
property taxes pay
for a safe neighborhood
and the poor neighborhoods
may not get lights.
Whoever's causing the
crime, whether it's
for economic opportunity by
the more, more powerful or out
of desperation,
the same people are
suffering with the people
in those communities.
Or why do people feel they don't
trust law enforcement states?
Or you could pay for a good
representation in court.
Or you can get a
state appointed one
that only gives your
case five seconds.
So I don't see that
those problems don't
exist in the quote
"nondeveloping world."
Have you given or
are there others
doing similar lines of research?
GARY HAUGEN: Yeah,
and that is the case
and as I said the
first half of my career
was addressing those
failures actually
here in the United States.
So there's no abuse taking
place overseas that I haven't
seen somewhere here
in the United States.
What we do have is just
massively greater resources
to address them.
But it's also true that
those with wealth and money
supplement the provision
of public service
with private security and with
private legal representation
and so forth.
And so it is certainly
true that you
get better security
the wealthier
you are in the United
States and in any country.
That's true, but the
question is whether or not
you're going to have any sort
of even reasonable baseline
of protection for those reports.
You might look at Katherine
Boo's recent book on, I think,
"Behind the Beautiful Forevers,"
where she lived for three years
in a slum in India.
And she's this
amazing journalist
who's actually written a lot
about the failures of law
enforcement in the
United States too.
But she wrote about just
the realities of poverty
in the slum, and one of the
things, when she came home
and she was on NPR, talking--
She says well, one thing I can
say is different about coming
home to the United States
is that the basic level of
opportunity for law enforcement
to provide basic
order in the community
is order of magnitude different.
It's also true for instance
that the poor-- and we have
mass incarceration of the
poor in the United States,
because of poor legal
services in many respects--
but what's true
in the developing
world is that if you're too
poor to have an attorney,
you get no attorney.
So you don't get a sleepy
attorney or a drunk attorney,
or you get none at all, and
it's ap overwhelmingly likely
that if you're a poor person
in the developing world,
you will appear in court in a
proceeding that is conducted
in a language you
do not understand.
So you will appear,
because actually conducted
in the colonial
language, whether that's
English or Spanish or French.
Because the legal
institutions were set up
by the colonial powers, and they
have never been re-engineered.
This is the other amazing thing.
The laws have changed?
Post-colonial
wonderful embedding
of human rights standards
in domestic law.
But the pipeline that
actually delivers those rights
is law enforcement, which has
been set up by a colonial model
and never changed.
And so one of the
things that manifests
is that you don't have
any representation at all.
And you do it in a
proceeding that's
conducted in a language
you don't understand.
So imagine, you're
accused of a crime.
You are thrown into a
proceeding in which you
have no legal protection.
And you can't understand a word.
And then you just get
shuffled off to jail.
And you're sort of
asking, as I see
this many times, the
defendant who's poor,
asking the guard, of course,
who has no education,
is illiterate generally,
but to ask the guard,
can you just please
explain what just happened?
So ever society needs
to carry vigilance
on behalf of those who are
poorest and most vulnerable,
who are going to get run over
by a criminal justice system,
But the utter collapse of these
systems in the developing world
is something, as we
wrote in another article,
you almost have
to see to believe.
And we're hoping to just
bring that to the surface.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just curious if you
had any thoughts on any ways
that information technology has
impacted this problem at all.
Have you seen this
through your work?
Are there things that
we could be doing?
You know, a big place like
Google-- that could help.
GARY HAUGEN: Massively so.
And in fact, we have
had some opportunities
to bring out our director
of investigations,
for example, who was
formerly the director of NCIS
to talk about the amazing ways
that actually technology can be
leveraged in on
behalf of the poor
to fight much of this crime.
In many ways in the
developing world,
these technological
advances are leapfrogging
in ways that are able to
empower the poor tremendously.
When I started doing this
work, there-- I know,
it's dating me a bit, but
there were no cell phones
in the developing world.
And now we give cell phones to
slaves inside brick factories.
And they are able to
communicate with us.
And then there's
using imagery to find
places that are more likely
to be using slave labor,
the way of creating
sort of hot spots
where abuse is
taking through data.
The truth is though
every word I just
used I was acting like I knew
what I was talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY HAUGEN: You guys are
more likely to be the ones
to actually get
to know the needs,
and then to begin to dream and
imagine what technology can do.
So that would be another
wonderful thing for you guys
to read the book, acquaint
yourself with the problems,
and then begin to imagine with
us the way in which technology
can be leveraged.
Because one of just absolute
things that technology
is able to do is to bring
transparency to what's
happening by empowering people
to signal what is happening
or communicate what's happening
and to shrink the world
and to do it to do it real time.
I think technology is
fundamentally just going
to make it harder
and harder and harder
to get away with these things.
And that is what the victims
of abuse and violence
need most is for other
people to know about it.
Because if you think about it,
what does a violent criminal
always do?
And its part of the thing
that makes them so scary
is they hide what
they do in the dark.
And they try to intimidate
other people from seeing it.
Why do they do that?
They do it because
they're afraid.
Criminals are
fundamentally afraid,
that if other people
know what's going on,
they won't be able to
withstand the power that we
brought to bear upon the theme.
So that way the technology can
bring us much more to actually
be transparent about what's
going on in the world
and empower even the weakest
to be able to do that.
I think we're going to be living
in a very different and safer
world for the poor.
PAUL LEE: Just join me
in giving Gary a hand.
Thanks for coming
over, appreciate it.